hello
anyone want to talk to me
he's everywhere in the shower isn't it
thanks guys
well i might as well just put my video
on
hi
everyone
hello i don't like your music very much
hi i'm ed sheeran lad bible have
released an avatar of me in leicester
square and we're gonna go surprise
people so ed if you want to mute and
turn your camera off
right avatar are you ready let's do this
avatar man so there's two girls over
there you see yep those two um go up to
that i think they might have heard a
song of mine wow hi am i going to be on
tv
oh hi
how are you guys doing
what how are you doing we're good yeah
uh who are you hi
your suit i'm so confused who do you um
who do you think i am
oh
tom harmon
tom holland
oh god this is going to be a
disappointment now isn't it
yeah the same to me i'm fresh
okay
harry style
how are you guys doing
most embarrassing moment of your life
i probably back in primary school when i
was like eight or nine
uh pissing myself i can still remember
it
no we've all been there we've been
there
can you take a picture with you of
course you can
can you just walk straight on okay
avatar man i would say those two kids
there can you see them yeah just call
them over are you guys are you guys
music fans we're shooting something for
a music station yeah yeah
yeah yeah
can you guys sing uh is is are there any
ed sheeran songs you know the lyrics to
uh yeah yeah
what's your favorite song um
photograph probably beautiful can you uh
do can you sing the first first placing
girl yeah
laughing can hurt sometimes
but it's the only thing that makes us
feel alive
we keep
on jesus oh my god
oh my god what are you guys doing i'm
good how are you filming a thing
we're filming something for uh the last
bible
at the moment but thank you for uh thank
you for being involved let me ask you a
question
all yes you first looks like all right
all right are you dressing up for
halloween i think i will dress up for
halloween yeah there's a program called
squid game and i want to go with one of
the guards from that because they're
just a mask because they weren't yeah do
you know what you should do you get
loads of bread and just tape it to
yourself and call you yourself the
gingerbread man bread bread sheeran
yeah anyway guys have a fantastic rest
today do you want to do it you want to
take a selfie
at some point we should pretend we're
making a documentary on people that
don't like my music
[Music]
[Music]
music that people don't like in uh the
uk right okay i would like to hear who
you hate the most
anything in the chat okay storms
ed sheeran's in the charts right right
sometimes
he's everywhere in the show isn't he
there's no point there's no point in
releasing an album when it releases one
because just he literally will win it
every time thanks guys
are you guys from from london yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm from suffolk actually same
neck of the woods as you so
your songs literally playing in the shop
right now
they literally are playing ship with you
right behind us for uh by pure
coincidence
well should we go in there should we get
yeah
okay let's keep walking then let's keep
we know when we're not wanted
hi guys do you want to come in do you
want to come in closer ask me some
questions
have you burned out have you broken um i
do pronounce like daily bugs
it doesn't help yeah ed i'm not gonna
lie my nan loves you i'm not a fan but
my nan
can you say hi to my name what's your
name's name
can you say hi to flora
flora flora thank you so much for liking
my music um uh you need to do a better
job with getting my music out there to
your granddaughter because she's not a
fan but uh but i'm glad i'm glad you're
a fan and lots of love
[Music]
avatar me i need you to do a 360 and
look around so we can choose somewhere
cool to go so just turn turn
around nope they don't want to go there
no
no like i still like stop stop stop stop
stop stop let go go in there okay i
would say walk in and
let's see if they have any massive
massive lego kits
hey
okay go in the tube go in the tube
all right just sit
sit in between shakespeare and
oh queen's behind me hello
all right sit down
there you go okay selfie with
shakespeare
if you go over to there to the to the
right these two
these two kids
what what do you want from the lego
store we'll buy it for you right now
you can choose you can choose anything
you want
all right so two harry potter lego sets
you choose them out now and we'll buy
them
guys you can choose any set you want it
can be bigger than that if you want
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god i didn't know they did the
chess set that's really cool yeah guys
say bye to everyone say bye
did i have a wonderful rest of your lego
experience
uh yeah you are you are going to buy
them right you're not just you're not
just going to put them put them back on
the shelf and break their hearts
please make sure you buy them
we will promise
[Music]
hello
anyone want to talk to me
do you want to come talk to me hello
god english people don't give a [ __ ]
come sit down
let's have a chat okay
i am i am a musician i'm from england
and uh i'm doing a thing called bible
can you guess who i am you can ask me
you can ask me five questions
oh man i'm not even from
here um
where are you from
wait let me just let me just put my
camera on
where you uh where are you from
i'm from san diego california oh my god
i'm a big fan of your as well
like
do you want to take a do you want to
take a selfie yeah sure
holy [ __ ] i've been listening to you
since i was like 12. oh my god
oh my
thank you
this is good we found a fan
one
[Music]
hello hello hello
how are you guys i'm good how are you
amazing good good stuff do you guys like
music
yes yeah we love music yeah we do yeah
who's your favorite musician
um
i like country music chris gableton
chris chris ableton did a a a good song
with them ed sheeran did you did yeah on
yeah on the uh collaborations album do i
put my video on now hello
oh my god
oh my god she's gonna freak out now
[Music]
hello
hi guys
hi
all right well it's going well
all right go forward go cool
okay keep walking keep looking to those
guys behind the camera they're trying to
avoid the camera
hi guys
[Music]
we need to get out of the quiet street
let's walk let's walk into a busy area
[Music]
you need to take it to tesco to uh
what do i do with it
you give them a tenner as well and then
they'll give you a cd
yeah but i don't like your music very
much
[Laughter]
oh my god hello
you see the guy in the red jacket just
go go go up to him and play galway girl
as loud as you can see later thanks guys
that was really fun thank you very much
for letting me do that uh yeah thanks
everyone
[Music]
i guess you can't do this again
because people will know there's a guy
with a
although they won't know who's behind
the thing dwayne the rock johnson would
be good i think
but get someone really tiny
[Laughter]
what is dwayne's signature wrestling
move is it a the man's shoulder is it b
the people's elbow or is it c the
gentleman's reach around
[Music]
okay